[Captioned via Y Translator]
In this video, we're going
to be taking a look at all
of the different suggested methods
for making ice that is completely clear.
There are several of them,
and some will work, and some won't.
We'll find out which.
[Music]
Ice is really cool,
and of course, I mean
that in multiple ways.
But what's even better is if you can
have ice that's completely clear.
You can see right through it.
But that's kind of
a hard effect to achieve.
Today, we're going to put
to the test several suggested methods
for how to get clear ice.
The basic idea is we'll have
a separate container for each
of our different methods
for making clear ice,
we'll let them all freeze,
and we'll see which one's work the best.
Here's what we're going
to try, boiling water,
letting it cool down,
and then boiling it again is
one that I've seen all over the place
as a sure fire method
for making clear ice.
Then there's the idea
that you can use distilled water,
and it's complete lack of impurities
will let the water crystallize
into a nice clear formation.
We're also going to try putting
some water in our vacuum chamber,
and letting that run
for a while to sort
of suck out any extra dissolved gases.
Hopefully, those won't
get trapped in the ice,
and that will let us get a clear result.
Then finally, we have a small cooler,
and we're just going to fill this most
of the way with water,
and put this freezer as well,
and see what happens
if we force all of the water
to freeze from one direction,
in this case, it will freeze
from the top down.
As a first step, let's fill
our small pot with water.
We'll boil it,
let it cool down back to room temperature,
and then boil it a second time
before pouring it into this container,
where will freeze it.
[Music]
This one's just
distilled water.
Distilled water is water that's been
run through a distilling process.
It's boiled off and the steam is
condensed back down into water,
and in theory, what you're left with
is water that's completely sterile,
and has nothing else in it.
So this should just be hydrogen
and oxygen atoms
bonded together in water form.
Nothing else.
[Music]
Okay.
Now, we've got some normal
tap water in one of our containers,
and we're going to vacuum it.
Not with a vacuum cleaner,
vacuum chamber.
We hit a low pressure.
That's about 25
inches of mercury.
It starts boiling and bubbling,
and the idea is that by putting it
in a vacuum chamber,
all of the extra dissolved gases
get pulled right out.
I'm not entirely sure how
that's supposed to work,
because we are obviously just creating gas
by causing it to boil at a low pressure.
There could be a level
where it pulls out gases
before adding more in.
Okay, I think our water
is good and vacuumed.
[Music]
Now, let's take our cooler,
and fill it most of the way.
We'll put that in the freezer,
and we'll let it freeze.
[Music]
Just to make sure we've really
exhausted all possibilities,
I took some distilled water,
I boiled it twice,
and then I ran it
in the vacuum chamber
for a while so we can get a test
of all three of these methods at once.
Before we check on that ice,
we want to talk a little bit
about Audible, the sponsor
for today's video.
Audible has the largest selection
of audio books, and they're always
adding new content
so they keep things fresh.
Something new that
they've just released
is called Audible Originals.
Audible Originals are
exclusive audio titles
created by celebrated storytellers
from things like theater, literature,
journalism, and more.
Since these Audible Original pieces
are made for and exclusive to audible,
you can't get them anywhere else.
Audible is offering new listeners
a free 30-day trial that comes
with one credit good
for an audiobook, and two
credits good for Audible Originals.
With Audible, all
of your media is yours to keep,
even if you cancel your membership.
You can go back at any time
and listen to pieces even
if you aren't currently a subscriber.
Recently, I've been listening
to the audiobook called
Legion: The Many Lives of Stephen Leeds
by Brandon Sanderson.
It's great because I love reading,
but I don't often like to sit still
long enough to read a hardcopy.
Get one free audiobook
and two Audible Originals when
you try Audible for free for 30 days.
Go to audible.com/thekingofrandom,
or text thekingofrandom to 500500.
That's
audible.com/t-h-e-k-i-n-g-o-f-r-a-n-d-o-m.
It's written right here.
There you go.
Good luck lining
that up editors.
All right.
Let's crack open the freezer,
and see how our ice is doing.
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I just have it locked.
Here we go.
We've got our distilled water,
we've got our vacuumed water,
and we have our boiled water.
I wonder if we can pop these--
Oh, yeah, that was easy.
[Music]
That was slightly
less easy, but...
Now, first Impressions.
They definitely all
have bubbles in them.
I have seen quite a
few comments talking
about how to get clear ice.
If you boil it,
that's going to work.
You're going to have
perfectly clear ice.
Well, not really.
Here is our twice boiled water,
and that, that has formed ice
with bubbles in the middle.
I'll give it something.
It is not cracked the way
that our other two are,
that might be a function of the boiling,
that might be a function of it
had slightly more or less water in it,
or its container was just a slightly
different flexibility level.
There it goes.
So with two of these,
as I place them under the water,
just to try and get more
of a clear surface,
we got some pretty gnarly cracks that form.
I mean, they're already had cracks,
but some new ones just popped
into existence.
Our distilled, our vacuumed,
and then are boiled in sort
of the order of most air bubbles
and ice damage to least air bubbles
and the ice damage.
However, I don't think
that it's necessarily
perfectly a function of being boiled.
I think there are other
factors at play here.
For example, I have here
a container in which I froze
distilled water that I boiled twice,
and then I put in the vacuum chamber,
so it's all three of these combined,
and honestly, it doesn't look any better
than the distilled water,
and maybe somehow distilled water
is just inherently worse
in terms of air bubbles.
I'm not sure.
Let's run this under some water,
hope the glass doesn't shatter,
and see if we can pop it out.
This is a glass container rather
than the plastic container.
In that very well could contribute
to the shape change,
and all of the cracking in there as well.
It's spinning in there,
but air can't get in
there to let it drop out.
There we go.
Our distilled, vacuumed,
boiled puck is...
Boy, that-- That might be
the worst one of all,
and that I believe is mostly
because it was in a glass container,
which had no flexibility.
So when that ice tried to start
expanding, it had nowhere to go
but to push itself up more.
Of course, if we had tried
to seal it in that glass container,
it probably would have just
shattered the container.
Ice does not like
to be contained.
Let's take a look at our last type of ice,
and that's the ice that we put into a cooler.
First Impressions is I can see
some air bubbles down in there,
but when I take a closer look,
it becomes obvious
that we actually have multiple inches
of perfectly clear ice
before we get to those bubbles.
So you can see
that those bubbles start
several inches down into the ice.
They're not immediately
up at the top here,
and what happened is our cooler made it
so that all of the cold could really only
go in through the top,
or rather the heat could
only escape out the top,
which means that the top
of the ice froze first,
and it froze down, down into the cooler,
and after, there were a
couple inches of frozen ice,
or maybe it's less than that.
I can't tell because it's going
to distort the light a little.
But it got a good ways down,
and then it froze under that,
and that part
has some bubbles trapped in it.
Those bubbles had know
where they could go.
They couldn't escape
out of our container.
Let's see if we can get
this whole ice block
out of our cooler.
This could be tricky.
That sounded good.
There we go.
There's our block.
Oh boy.
That's--
That's fantastic.
[Music]
So now we can see
how much clear ice
we're getting out of this.
I'd say we have an inch
and a half of ice
with no bubbles in it,
and then we have very
very minimal bubbles
for another 3/4 of an inch,
and then after that
is where the real bubbles really start.
Let's see if we can't cut our clear ice
off of our white ice.
[Music]
Having melted and chipped away most
of the white portion of the ice,
you can see how clear we are this point.
Let's just set it down here,
and look through it like that.
Obviously, there are still
some little bubbles in here,
and if you wanted to make sure
you didn't have any of those,
there's a few things I'd recommend.
First is actually taking
the ice out sooner.
Don't let it freeze all the way through,
but just have it freeze for the top inch
and a half or so,
and then take the cooler out,
take your ice block out
and use it however you like.
The way that I've done it
is just to demonstrate why
we get bubbles in the ice.
We get bubbles in the ice
because there is gas
trapped in the water,
and we can't get that out
by boiling it or by vacuum chambering it,
but it's going to have gas
and contaminants in the water even
if we use distilled water,
vacuum it, boil it, all of that.
But if we freeze it from only
one direction, then they all
sort of get pushed out of the way,
and we get some nice,
beautifully clear ice
before we get to the portions
that are going to cause problems.
Before we get to the bubbles and stuff,
and then those will get
pushed to the bottom.
So this is the only way that
I have found to freeze
clear ice at home.
Thanks again to Audible
for sponsoring today's video.
Check the link in the description,
or go to audible.com/thekingofrandom
to start your free trial,
and get one free audiobook,
and two free Audible Originals.
That's it for today,
but the fun doesn't end here.
That box at the top
will take you directly
to our most recent video,
and you can go check that out.
The other box will show
you what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next,
and if you're not a subscriber
to the channel yet,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you'll never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.